like eastern and horizon ridge and
henderson and every day while he's
spinning he's waving at everyone and you
just get i was like
i was waving like this guy's awesome i
bet it's good for anxiety too science
yeah you know
they're very talented very talented i
just want that agent's analysis yeah
where'd they get that
promotions hey you know what you should
do you should spin a sign during your
forecast and then point to the numbers
yeah that's a good idea
no it's not
[Laughter]
look outside this is our strat cam i
like your thinking those lofty that was
good all right live look to the north
this is our strat cam looking at the
spring
the sheep range i should say in las
vegas range clear skies out there
and the winds are now starting to calm
down a little more here's the latest on
our pond report though mulberry ash we
know that's high this time there because
we're all sneezing alder now is up to
the high reading air quality though good
that could change a little for tomorrow
currently outside 83 in centennial hills
somewhere at 79 84 downtown in north las
vegas mid 80s for sunrise manor green
valley at 85 80 for roads ranch 83
henderson the temperatures are going to
be very comfortable for tonight since we
warmed back up to those 80s 84 in prep
82 boulder city 88 for you in lothan and
mesquite got a lot of viewers up there
86 for you right now so high pressure
again warming us up that's going to be
around through the weekend before we
start to see some changes from this
system out here that's going to dive
down and push that high towards the
south and east what that's going to do
is it dives down it's going to increase
our winds and also cool us off big time
first of all let's focus on those winds
although we will see breezy winds over
the weekend the strongest winds i think
are going to be monday and tuesday this
is when we could see wind alerts issued
if they are they usually our weather
team will let you know about that ahead
of time on social and of course online
and then we'll see those breezes still
around also for wednesday too shower
chances nothing expected until we get to
tuesday where we do have chances now for
some isolated showers around the region
and look at lowering snow levels where
we'll get some snow possibly up the
mountains there too that's out of here
though by tuesday afternoon and evening
and then wednesday we're in the clear so
hopefully tuesday we'll get some showers
in here because we certainly need the
raindrops 61 overnight cool and nice
light breezes we'll be in the 70s for
this evening 89 tomorrow that's warmer
than today for sure lighter winds now
remember our average is 76 this time of
year
so we're going to be way above average
and even warmer by the time we get to
saturday look at our record at 95
degrees we'll come close to that more
clouds on sunday and there's a look at
those winds monday and tuesday this
kickoff spring break it's not going to
feel like it 64 on tuesday and then back
to normal in those mid 70s by later on
in the week
that is your most accurate forecast back
to you